dr anthony fauci has served under seven
presidents
and led america's response to hiv aids
ebola and zika
but during the kovid 19 pandemic
he found himself at odds with his
president battling misinformation
and targeted by personal attacks
did you hear that tony they want you
locked up
is this a passing phase
or is there something broken about
science and politics in america
[Music]
is it good enough for scientists to say
i'm just a political you know i can
stand aside from the science well we
should be a political and that's what we
and i certainly have tried to be but
unfortunately
when you get
um
totally politically motivated
inaccuracies
get thrown into the picture like the
claims that the interventions worked
when there was no indication
whatsoever that they work none at all
and it was taken as
a one person's word is as good as
another well when you're dealing with
science
one person's word is not as good as
another
the science determines what is the
correct
answer to a particular question you
yourself became a politicized figure so
as you were became a hero to someone and
a villain to others
how did you
attempt to hold that position of
neutrality what was your your strategy
my strategy is to always stick with the
science
be flexible enough that when new
information
evolves
in an evolving outbreak
to make sure that you're flexible enough
to modify your position on public health
issues
um i've done that
to the best of my ability but
the political issues that have come in
you get accused of flip-flopping now
that's very interesting because if
scientists
did not change
their approach to things as new data
evolved they would be violating the
principles of science
and yet that has been interpreted as
flip-flopping the other situation
that i think triggered it
for me
is that when i was part of the
white house coronavirus task force
in the trump administration i was put in
the very uncomfortable position to
actually have to contradict the
president of the united states
who is a very politically polarized
president as you know at the time
and
it was something i was really quite
uncomfortable in doing i took no
pleasure at all i have a phenomenal
respect
for the institutions of my country
including the presidency
and the various
forms of government the legislative and
judicial branch
and the idea that i had to
at great discomfort
come out and essentially contradict and
correct the president that created
a
sort of a groundswell of
antithesis towards me or antipathy
that's the right word towards me on the
part
of the far right who were very much
you know aligned with trump um and all
of a sudden
i became the opposition
which was really unfortunate because i
was really being guided
purely by the science has it changed
your view of of public service i i mean
if if you were talking to a young
scientist now
would you say
look just stay in the lab and to do the
research um you know you could you can
do an awful lot of good writing papers
and researching into diseases
or would you still say look public
service is the thing to do
i would be very upset
if qualified young people
refrain from entering into public
service
because if they see what what i and some
of my scientific colleagues
are going through it is really
extraordinary you are probably aware
that when you have disagreements
disagreements are healthy
particularly when you discuss the basis
of the disagreement but now when you
have
scientists like myself and i'm i'm not
alone in this
who come out with a
science-based opinion they wind up
getting death threats
that's very common it's not it's not a
rarity it's it's quite common
that is
very disturbing and i really do hope
that we see our way
out of that
because that i think is going to
interfere
with the normal and appropriate
discourse and agreements and
disagreements and discussions when if
you give an opinion that disagrees with
somebody
you get threatened your family get
threatened that's really very bad news
i think we are living
right now
in a
society
both domestic here in the united states
and in some respects
globally
of
rather significant divisiveness
where something
like a public health issue
becomes
politicized and is influenced
by political ideology i mean we had
disagreements
when we had
hiv and
political differences with ebola and
political differences when we're dealing
with zika and all that
but never was it such
that there was such a profound
difference
in which in many respects
things that were completely untrue
are accepted by large numbers of people
and you have these
differences of opinion of things that
should not be any differences because
they're just facts
i'm sachin outer executive editor at the
economist
this was part of a digital event
produced exclusively for subscribers to
the economist if you'd like to watch the
full recording of this or any of our
other events please click the link
you'll have to register first or you can
subscribe to the economist and enjoy all
of our journalism thanks for watching